game number 54 on the season and what
will be the final week of this regular
season and the last home stand of the
year and it begins with the i-70 series
cardinals and they'll see
carlos hernandez for the first time
tonight making his second big league
start yeah they will i'm sure they've
seen some hard throwers before but man
i'll tell you what this young man he's
way more mature than his age might be at
23. and that'll bring up paul
goldschmidt
and he swings to the first pitch and
lines it to center and bubba starling
makes a diving tumbling catch for the
second out bubba froze and then he came
in as he read the spin and he read how
hard the ball was hit it just really
helps out hernandez there so now he gets
paul de young
and he struck him out with a slider
so hernandez has a scoreless top of the
first inning
that kind of year for adam wainwright he
has been sensational for st louis he has
been unreal he is going to work again
you know he's locked and loaded the face
of the franchise right now is probably
the man coming up alberto mondeci
swung on and missed and the first
strikeout for adam wainwright here's
matt carpenter
and carpenter hits a high fly ball out
to a deep right center at the wall gone
he loves it in kansas city
one to nothing cardinals
that is a good way
to strike first in a ball game and
here's michael franco
inside corner and the strikeout of
franco hey franco's not happy but this
is a strike i mean he set him up so well
for this pitch a couple of cutters on
the outer half through the one way off
and then just spots up perfect pitchers
pit
so runner at third with two down to paul
deyoung who struck out on three pitches
his first time up
but there's a good recovery from the
inning
second time he struck him out on three
pitches and the cardinals end up
scoreless in the third
veteran alex gordon leads off for the
kansas city royals next pitch from wayno
is a called strike three on the outside
corner
and that had a little bit extra plate to
it and gordon not happy with it but his
strikeout number three
for wayne up bubba starling hitting 189.
curveball and a beauty for adam
wainwright that's four strikeouts
for the 39 year old
[Applause]
and a grounder a hit to colton wong
adam wainwright has given up one hit and
he is struck out four
and he's through three it's one nothing
at carpenter homered into the water in
right center field
a called third strike
carpenter's upset ron culpa has been
calling that pitch all night
and that's hernandez third strikeout
nice little
arm side run is what they call that on
the outer half of the plate salvador
perez made it look good
and carp you got to go
tyler o'neal
he went around
that's manny gonzalez and it's
back-to-back strikeouts for hernandez
salvador perez lined into a double play
back in the first inning 2-1 pitch
curveball lifted in the air
out to deep left center
carlson up ball he got it dylan got it
what a catch from the rookie
dylan carlson up against the wall
robbing salvador perez
wayne wright has set down the last 11
royals
and now make it 12 and
the royals are mindful of that breaking
ball but he's surprising them with the
fastball now the royals have runners at
second and third and one out
jammed and here comes franco
and there is no play at the plate so i
don't know what the
exit velocity was on that ball
i don't know what franco's sprint speed
was coming down from third but it worked
and the royals tie the game
100 so stomat is sharp tonight three up
three down with a strikeout nikki lopez
will lead off
and there's old uncle charlie back at it
again strikeout number six now bond to
seat
swaying and a miss and there it is again
the curveball that's number seven and
the bases will be loaded
grounded fair up the right field line
that'll get two to the plate
so michael franco
went against the shift and he got one by
goldsmith who was quite a ways off the
line
and the royals take a three to one lead
in the sixth inning
here's solaire
nice jorge solaire hits one up the line
and he'll pick up his
first rbi since returning from the
injured list
and now the royals lead by three in the
eighth inning good swinging
welcome back
two down and dexter fowler
a called third strike
and it's been a strike zone like that
all night and the royals
hold on to the three-run lead tonight